If we've learned anything about
Islamists in the UK, it's that we can
definitely trust these guys around young
girls. Islamist men and little girls go
together like peanut butter and jelly,
fish and chips, needle and thread,
hammer and nail, bees and flowers, ants
and candy, hyenas and antelopes, Hamas
and music festivals, Candace Owens and
reality. So, we should all be thrilled
that East London Mosque continues
building bridges between Islamists and
little girls. The London Evening
Standard reports, London Mosque faces
criticism over men and young girls only
charity fun run. East London Mosque
sparks criticism over the charity run
open to men and girls under 12 only.
Criticism. Criticism.
Why would there be criticism? I thought
this is what the UK wanted. A mosque is
facing criticism over entry rules for a
charity fund run. The 5 km run being
held in London's Victoria Park build as
inclusive and familyfriendly is only
open to men and girls under the age of
12. The Muslim charity run has been
organized by East London Mosque and was
due to take place in London's Victoria
Park on Sunday. To be fair, grown men
and little girls would be considered
familyfriendly in Islam. Just look at
this passage from Sahil Bkari. Notice
the chapter heading. Giving one's young
children in marriage is permissible.
Why? by virtue of the statement of Allah
and for those who have no monthly
courses, no monthly period, i.e. they
are still immature. That's surah 65
verse4 of the Quran. And the ida, the
ida is the waiting period for a girl
after a grown man has married her and
had sex with her and decided to divorce
her. If a grown man marries a
prepubescent girl and divorces her, she
has to wait 3 months before another
grown man can marry her. And the ida for
the girl before puberty is 3 months in
the above verse of the Quran. And to
illustrate Allah's ruling in the Quran,
Bkari quotes Aisha saying that Muhammad
had sex with her when she was only 9
years old. narrated Aisha that the
prophet wrote the marriage contract with
her when she was 6 years old and he
consummated his marriage when she was 9
years old and then she remained with him
for 9 years i.e. till his death.
So grown men running around with little
girls is familyfriendly fun in Islam
because it's how families get started in
Islam.
Baroness Shya Gohir, Obbe, the chief
executive of the Muslim Women's Network
UK, told the Mail on Sunday that the
organizers were likely in breach of the
Equality Act. Kelly J. Keen, founder of
feminist group Party of Women, said
banning women and girls over the age of
12 from a public charity event is
plainly unlawful and reinforces
regressive sexist attitudes towards
women's place in public life. No charity
should be allowed to operate under a
different set of rules because of
religion or culture. Equality before the
law must apply to everyone.
It's kind of weird to see Baroness
Shyistgo here complaining about the men
and young girls only charity fund run
because she normally complains about
Islamophobia.
>> The Muslim Women's Network UK has
launched a new initiative, the Muslim
Heritage Month. It is in response to the
rising and concerning levels of
Islamophobia in the UK.
>> My lords, I'm publishing a report today
called Anti-Muslim Hate Concerns and
Experiences. There's 4 million Muslims
in Britain. It's the largest minority
community and we are deeply deeply
worried about our safety. Online social
media spaces, public commentators, I
think media as well pushing a very
anti-Muslim rhetoric. It talks about
improving the way Islamophobia is
monitored and I welcome that. But what
action will the government do to tackle
anti-Muslim prejudice? She could have
said also tackle Islamophobia. So if I
say something about the treatment of
women and girls in Islam, I'm a racist,
Islamophobic, hate-mongering bigot. But
when Baroness Shygo here points out a
problem, she's just being a good Muslim
feminist.
Weird how there are always, always,
always different rules for Muslims and
non-Muslims.
However, the mosque strongly denies
claims the event breaches equality
legislation. A spokesman said, "The
suggestion that our event breaches the
Equality Act is entirely incorrect.
Single gender sporting events are lawful
under section 195 and schedule 23 of the
act." They're pretty up on this, aren't
they? and are common across the UK,
including the women's run series, Nike
Women's 10K, and gender segregated
swimming sessions at Orthodox Jewish
facilities like Manchester Jewish
Community Center. The Muslim charity run
operates under the same legal framework
as these established events. Did you see
what they did right there? They said,
"Well, there are women onlyly sports and
activities in the UK, so we're obviously
allowed to keep our events segregated."
That's brilliant. It's evil, but
brilliant. They twist the law to enforce
Sharia. There are women onlyly sporting
events in the UK to protect women from
competing against men, and there are
women onlyly spaces to protect women
from men. But the East London Mosque
didn't segregate their charity run to
keep women from competing against men.
They're not even segregating based on
gender. They have little girls running.
They're segregating based on age. No
older girls or grown women allowed, but
little girls are welcome to participate.
Now, the reason for banning women and
girls over 12 from the event is that
many Muslims don't believe that free
mixing is allowed in Islam. Free mixing
refers to unnecessary social
interactions between men and women who
aren't related. But I see two glaring
problems here. First, as we've seen, 12
isn't some magical age in Islam.
Muhammad married a six-year-old girl.
And even popular Muslim speakers admit
that Islam allows marriage to young
girls.
>> Could a uh could a man have a marriage
to a 5-year-old consummate if she
started precocious puberty?
>> If she starts showing signs of physical
maturity, then yes, that's permissible.
As I stated, that's what age
>> if there are signs of
>> so this is something that becomes
biologically impossible because
precocious pert.
So all the five-year-old and
six-year-old and sevenyear-old and
8-year-old and 9-year-old and 10year-old
girls in that race are fair game for
Muslim men. If the goal of keeping older
girls and women segregated is to keep
men from lusting after them, the younger
girls should also have been excluded.
Why weren't they excluded?
Second, this is what we call creeping
Sharia. Everyone is shocked when they
find out that women aren't even allowed
to speak in public in Afghanistan.
But popular Muslims in the UK don't
allow their wives to speak in public.
Ali Dawa, who has over 1.3 million
followers on YouTube, has his wife
communicate using a whiteboard. But
she's going to have her say um with this
whiteboard that I bought her.
Okay, that's something my wife wants to
say. Uh, Salama probably had enough as
woman give out. Okay, she's saying him.
She made the video, not him. I don't
know his opinion. People think what
happens in Afghanistan stays in
Afghanistan.
But what happens in Afghanistan doesn't
stay in Afghanistan because one, the UK
government keeps importing Muslims from
Afghanistan. And two, the Taliban didn't
invent these ideas.
These ideas are part of Islam, the
religion that now has more than 1.3
million adherence in London alone.
The UK is being Islamized day by day,
week by week, month by month, year by
year.
When non-Muslims complain about it,
Muslim feminists like Baroness Shygo
here call us Islamophobes.
Muslim feminists think they can stop the
Islamists all by themselves just as they
stopped the Islamists nowhere ever.
Sorry, Muslim feminists, but you're not
going to stop the Islamists because
you're paving the way for the Islamists.
You're the useful idiots who silence the
people who are trying to help you and
help the people who are trying to
silence you.
Have fun with your whiteboards.
You
proud on that. You proud on that. You
just fine on me. You proud on that. You
just back on me. This is a powerful
religion. There's a reason to it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.